good morning john i think a medicine
that increases my chances of getting
skin cancer so every year i have to go
see a dermatologist to check and make
sure that all my skin cells are acting
all nice and respectful and none of them
are stepping out of line and trying to
kill me so far this has always gone fine
that one time they did take a biopsy of
a thing in my foot only to discover that
it was pieces of a pinecone that i
stepped on when i was in high school at
my most recent dermatology visit there
was a med student in the room doing one
of the 20 000 things you have to do in
order to become a doctor you wrap it all
up they leave i put my clothes back on i
walk outside and she says i just want to
thank you so much for crash course and
that feels so good every single time
even if they just saw my butt and this
happens frequently yesterday i was at
the coffee shop with oren because it's
his first day of summer vacation two
people thank me for crash course one of
them is starting nursing school this
week john when we started crash course i
certainly hoped that it would be
successful in helping students learn and
i couldn't have told you that it would
be successful and i much less could have
told you why it would be successful but
now i do understand that and i want to
explain it to you we started crash
courses youtubers which i didn't think
about at the time but it turns out that
really mattered because when you're on
youtube you have to compete in a very
specific environment and there's two
ways you can beat one you have to grab
and hold on to people's attention and
second you have to do it inexpensively
because on youtube you make like 10 to
100 times less per minute of content you
produce than on television now to make
educational content hold onto people's
attention you just have to make it
really good you have to be conveying a
lot of information to people keep their
attention keep them from looking at the
sidebar and getting distracted to do it
inexpensively you have to basically take
out everything that isn't doing that and
that is what created crash courses laser
focus on what we talk about all the time
now which is lowering barriers to
education and there are from where i set
two major barriers to learning one is
access can you afford it is it available
where you are were you accepted into the
program etc but second and often ignored
is the actual barrier of learning the
world is complex and you need
well-trained experts to get complicated
ideas into other people's heads if it
were easy people wouldn't be taking out
tens of thousands of dollars of student
loans to get it done crash course lowers
that barrier as much as it can by being
as good as it can be by finding the
stories to tell the ways to
contextualize the information in ways
that matter to students by emulating
some of the style of the content that
they are already familiar with an
appreciation that first barrier the
barrier to access we solve that by not
just being free but by being available
to everyone who has an internet
connection and a strong understanding of
the english language but we have done of
course in arabic and we're working on a
biology course in spanish right crash
course is on youtube because it is where
people are it is where students are and
teachers and learners because
everybody's on youtube they spend time
there they feel comfortable there they
understand the interface it's in a place
they are already choosing to spend time
we can't be out there trying to sell our
stuff to school districts and they buy
all of it and then it kind of gets
forced on the teachers no we just want
to be there and let teachers and
students pick what they want to choose
so that the only time that crash course
gets used is when students or teachers
find it useful and if my inability to
get a mold check without someone
thanking crash course for helping them
get through their education is any
indication i think that crash course has
a pretty big impact the entire goal has
to be about optimizing learning for
learning about getting those barriers
down as low as we can get them you can't
eliminate them but you can get them
lower and why is that important
because the entire human story is about
how effective we are at helping each
other learn but pushing those barriers
down isn't easy we reach a lot of people
at crash course and we try to keep our
budget low but it costs a lot of money
37 percent of our budget comes from our
patreon and from the crash course coin a
beautiful coin minted in arkansas from
hand engraved dies we've sold out of the
10 000 learner coins but the 2022 2000
learner coins are still available and
will be through this weekend but then
never ever again if you want to help
crash course do this work and you have a
hundred dollars to spare and i totally
understand if you do not there's a link
in the description john i'll see you on
tuesday
[Music]
you